[музика]
Всім привіт Мене звати миненко Анастасія
Я Радом з городні Мені 16 років хочеться
розвивати нашу громаду хочеться
розвивати своє місто тому що зараз в
країні війна багато людей виїхало і мало
людей приїжджають але хочеться щоб місце
процвітало а тому Ми створюємо різні
проекти і якісь різні заходи для цього
розмальовували шкільне укриття шкільне
укриття в музичній школі Якщо саме для
зс ми ми робили свічки плили сітки різні
взагалі допомагали в якихось грошових
зборах допомагала з
гуманітаркою Ми живемо в країні яку
треба розбудовувати розвивати хочеться
почати саме з мого рідного міста з мого
рідного краю щоб люди хотіли сюди
приїхати тут
[музика]
залишитися